what we like to call it on our show is
current thing enforcers the current
thing enforcers that really and and this
isn't just the media it's it's your
run-of-the-mill liberals on the internet
now too that you know they put the right
flag at that at the right time on their
Twitter bio you know they're enforcing
this sort of lockstep thing Tim that
you're describing here and then they've
sort of made it their lives their lives
work to sort of uh attack people who
challenge that I don't know where that
comes from why people dedicate their
lives to this but it's fascinating and
it's only come in the last few years and
then you know I mean that DHS uh uh
disinformation board that Nina jankow
was remember they were going to create
that Ministry of Truth the government
was going to tell us you know what the
truth was they actually tried to they
actually tried to uh institutionalize
this current thing enforce her her job
was basically going to be to be the
Karen of the internet yeah yeah